I thought I'd do something different
today,
so I haven't given this talk before.
I'm going to tackle the issue of free
speech.
From a left wing perspective,
it's actually dead simple to provide a
left wing rationale for free speech.
It should be self evident to people who
are pursuing social justice,
that the most potent weapon in their
artillery is the ability to communicate.
What do people who lack power have other
than their ability to speak on their own
behalf and isn't it on their behalf?
That the right to speak must be most
jealously guarded.
Anyway,
I thought I would begin with a crucial
observation.
There's a fundamental structural reason
why our political system has developed
both a left and a right wing,
and that's the tendency for scarce
resources to become unequally
distributed.
So let's discuss that.
In my clinical practice.
I once had a client,
an older guy in his eighties he'd come
to me after his wife had died because he
was lonesome,
but also because he was obsessed mostly
with mathematical ideas.
Sasha
[inaudible],
he and
I showed it to a woman in our department
who was also very [inaudible] start by
the moment you saw it didn't pretty have
the same effect on me because I'm not
someone who sees,
I'm not mathematically gifted enough to
seek beauty in symbol that represents
that sort of thing.
Anyways,
I got to know him pretty well and was
actually in some sense he was paying me
to uh,
you just kind of a car to me because I
certainly heard it as much or more from
him.
And he did for me is Greece.
And I also help him like,
hey,
come to terms with this mathematical
obsession.
He put the stop thinking about
mathematical issues,
but that was more or less just the way
he was.
I mean,
he was wired that way.
Um,
and you know,
we felt bad about the substance,
but if you're an obsessive genius,
that's just life.
You know,
there are people like that and they're
not that common and it's a good bit.
There are some of them and he was one of
them.
He had been a psychology.
Stupid is you are.
Then he switched into economics and
tried to learn how big his fortune,
but she had been quite successful up and
he introduced me to some concepts that I
have encountered which shocked me.
It shocked me because the concepts to be
introduced me to [inaudible]
fundamental,
a fundamental importance and I couldn't
believe that I had gone through so much
education and so much further education
and research and develop a certain
expertise in statistics.
Although I know statistical expert
without encountering cause.
This said ideas and he introduced me to
web hasn't been come to be known as,
oh it's the work of bill friend.
They'll fred old pareto who was an
Italian economist and also the work of
Derek,
the solo price.
Who is someone who is studying
scientific productivity?
That's the 1960s he wrote a book called
big signs,
little science.
I tried to get a copy of it,
go on Amazon,
try addition again.
I believe the first edition fled to the
south of France.
They never were selling for about 630
bucks,
which is quite staggering.
And it shows you how interested people
are and after to get a piece of work.
And so I'll tell you about just all
price first and then I'll tell you about
[inaudible] and the three of
distribution.
So just old price was interested in
scientific productivity and basically
index scientific product candidate by
looking at how many sites and get papers
to him.
Scientists publish it and side of the,
Sir I'll set up with precise,
but there they're also obsessed with
their seismic publication record because
well,
they,
they liked status just like the next
person.
And a status has to be measured and,
and uh,
and track and communicated partly
because,
well,
you have to promote people and you have
to assess them and you have to hire
them.
So you'd have to rank order them.
And so if you all keep track of people's
accomplishments that you do that for
under stupidly,
and then you don't hire or promote or
replace the proper people.
So the scientific community has
organized itself very well and keeps
very tight to trap.
I'll different metrics of research post
let's say.
And so one of the most would be number
of papers published peer reviewed
journals and that's a pretty good one.
As it turns out,
pure nominator is actually as it turns
out,
a very excellent index of scientific
quality.
Um,
partly because generally speaking,
quality and quantity in a productive
field are quite tightly correlated and
reasonably how it is.
Well,
it's kind of obvious the more you
practice at something,
the better the tenant to get out.
So quantity quality tends to be typing
into interlake,
but there are other indexes like the
quality of the journal that you publish
in and that's indexed by the average
number of citations that give,
given the paper might get.
And Psyche,
she copies an indication of impact,
right?
If no one was sites your word,
like 80% of published humanities papers
at zero citations,
a polling people writing those papers,
there's published in journals,
a is buying them zero people read them,
scan,
cat scan.
He said it's a financial scampi does for
a very,
very expensive and that was just
published them because they're expensive
and libraries and path to buy divided.
And so the library is by them,
even though they wouldn't release,
doesn't know insights that they staff
the is the feminine,
they increase the ratio of noise to
signal and we subsidize that.
It's no longer to television.
It's one of the reasons because the bees
are dying,
probably not fast enough.
[inaudible]
free to fire up,
let's say more classical approach,
the heart of the university and they no
mistake about if you get universities,
you've got the tech stuff and somebody
could stuff that can be parceled out
either other agencies and existence to
take care of that humanity humanities at
the heart of the university we lose the
university university and now it's a
terrible thing,
but it's not as terrible as having them
continue on the path that they're
authorized down language back to
productivity.
So this Sol price was curious about who
is productive and what the differences
in productivity were.
And he had he,
he hoped data being average number of
publications that a phd student had.
And this was in the early sixties upon
graduation,
how the rates have gone up since then,
but I've already graduation,
we're pretty sure that the,
you mentioned some tape to say in terms
of what we're discussing,
grace of God so that the median number
of publications,
which is the typical number don't be
hours number,
right?
The typical number that people would
produce was one,
one publication and then you might say,
well okay fine,
the medium person published one,
how many people publish to and hash it
out was half as many as publish one.
And then the other question was,
well how many people publish straight?
He has those houses.
Then he has published two and four was
half as many as three.
Five is half as many as four.
And so what you see isn't it scattered
the rapid drop off of productivity,
but as you,
as you move upward in number of
publications and there's a,
there's a side effect to that.
So,
so imagine breath.
What happens is if you're,
if you're graphing come rip people out
of a particular number of publications,
you have the vast majority of people
that have one pop as many to half as
many of these that as three,
four,
five and then you'd get out of,
so here in the how,
maybe like 10 or maybe 20 and those
people are,
well,
they're super geniuses in her field
right there.
They're unbelievably smart girl,
unbelievably fast.
There are unbelievably productive
and it was hard to them.
And so price being an observation about
the scientific productivity and it's a
terrible,
terrible observation.
It's a hate fact.
He observed that if you took a domain of
scientific productivity and you were
trying to figure out who did it for
doctor work,
he answered grossed out.
It was the square root of the number of
disparities,
the number of people who are operating
in that particular specialization
produced half of the publications.
Now it's worthwhile thinking this
through.
So let's say you're a candidate,
people in a particular,
this also employs applies to the
employee productivity.
Incorporations pilate saying general
rehearsal.
So if you got 10 employees,
three of them do have to work.
Well that's not surprising.
You have people who don't do any
anymore.
You have some people who don't solve in
the work that they actually cost you
money.
It's that,
that's the estimate.
There's four,
if I remember correctly,
65% of managers at that negative
mentality you to become,
well,
it's hard growing company,
it's easy to save one and they,
and they fail all the time.
Okay,
so you have 10 free.
You have to work on that because it
seems so bad.
Well,
if you have 25 five you have to work.
That's getting rough.
Do you have a hundred is 10 if you have
a thousand
well it's hard to any,
it's third.
So what does that mean?
It means that
productivity is distributed in a manner
that was described by bill,
frito retail.
And that's the free or distribution.
And when you looked at the distribution
of income and the distribution of
wealth,
it's prudent Mr View,
which means that almost everyone has not
and a few people have a little bit and
then even fewer people have a little bit
more than that.
And there's some people,
they'll ace for example,
Carlos Slim,
um,
Jeff Bezos who have more money than God
anyway,
say,
well that's a consequence of improper
social structure.
And the right response to that is no,
it's not.
It's actually something more akin to
international law.
It governs the same distribution,
garners the size of cities.
That's an interest to take.
It also governs decisive planetary
bodies.
That's harder to blame on the
patriarchy.
But
he also seems to govern the
distribution,
every single thing that you would be
produced creatively.
So for example,
and I mean everything,
it's really quite staggering.
So if,
if it applies to a number of hockey
goals score for example,
um,
set,
set something like Wayne Gretzky,
I read if you took away all his is
actually gold,
you'd still have more points than any
occupated never late and so ill and get
a shot.
That's really interesting it because
they didn't tell us 1%.
No,
it's spot.
It's like one 10th of one 10th of 1% of
all the people who play hockey get into
the NHL like no one.
Right.
Give it up.
It's not,
it does happened.
And you're like the allergenic Gel guy.
Like you're a superstar and then there's
some son of a bitch like the redskins.
We'll just stay home piece in all of
these,
in all of these,
still making some pre production.
I can tell you people were kind of
brands like either it old fashion.
So you can talk about Pablo Castle.
He's an interesting character.
Yeah,
they're long productive lives.
Right.
Hit it.
If I remember correctly,
it's nineties.
Why may I know how many,
how many more hard macassar produced and
you know,
you might get,
these are just sketches that he was like
just thrown off,
but don't make that go onto the online,
the castle archive.
We're 50,000 of them have to be
documented and I can give you the way,
my punchline.
But so,
so,
so I thought about it and then I did
some research to find out how many
artworks,
this crazy character,
but bruce,
and the answer was 65,003 day,
every single day for 65 years.
So I try
to do right.
I mean he wasn't just obsessively
producing artworks,
although he was there like a huge
proportion of those things were
masterpieces,
right?
So this was no pike of this guy.
He was,
he was something else.
And then Bach is a good example.
Care as far as,
well,
um,
he wrote so much music then it wouldn't
take a capias 45 years of eight hour
days just to copy what he had to
propose.
So these people are,
they're off the scale with regards to do
what they do.
You know,
when you see the same thing,
if you're looking at pat with numbers
and that sort of thing and so,
so depressed.
She is,
this is,
this is a really interesting all of
that.
The question is two questions.
Why in the world is the world set up
like that?
That's the first question.
And the second question is
what would make,
since it makes everything radically
unfair in a sense,
at least with regards to distribution,
maybe,
maybe it's,
it's good because those people are
producing things like that and the rest
of us,
at least in principle get oily.
But nonetheless,
there was a big problem with in terms of
inequality,
of,
of distribution ability and all of these
things.
Why,
why is that the case?
Well,
here's one reason.
So in this is something I've worked on,
at least in part with my,
with my client.
Um,
who else would have a theory on societal
revolutions,
which I think was pregnant,
intelligent theory.
Um,
he introduced me to a,
a field of inquiry that I had never
heard about.
People were holding,
he caught on physics and I didn't know
there were quantum physicists,
but there are,
and sometimes they're very productive
and the other ones are
the economy businesses figured out that
you could model the distribution of
money in a population,
usually the same equations that you
could log in with the distribution of a
gas into a vacuum.
So,
so there's a deep interpret like
phenomena driving the distribution of
money.
And so,
and here's how it works while you guys
are hopefully to the mall,
right?
And so,
but often just basically a random walk.
I mean,
you know how to play it off when you buy
it an you can as fast as you can.
And the first it was the luckiest,
the way it is.
That's basically the health and all the
work.
You know,
there's a lot of company,
are you going to say a skill?
There's sort of a modicum of stupidity,
stupid play you lose.
But barring that,
it's random walk and you know that,
cause we played 10 monopoly games,
it's very unlikely that you're going to
win more than your random sharer.
So let's think about what happens in an
office.
The first thing that happens is you
start from a position of equity.
Everybody has exactly the same amount of
money and then you engage in brandon
training,
essentially chicken,
the guys,
right?
And so what happens?
Well,
what happens is,
so here's the graph.
One Bar,
here's number of people,
or people are playing,
they all have exactly the same amount of
money,
think it's like $2,000 to begin with or
something like that.
Then you started shaking your ducks and
then go starts to happen is a few people
start to granted it more and a few
people start to lose a bit more.
And what happens to the waiters is that
they become more resilient,
right?
They can take more losses than the
people who are starting to lose.
And so what happens is the distribution
flattens out.
Couple of people get more of the word
money.
One person pulls up if the lead,
some people get less money and the loser
starts to develop and you keep shaking
the dice as soon.
What happens is they hang,
someone gives zero.
Now zero is a terrible number and you
can see this in all sorts of ways.
For example,
if you're trying to start a business,
zero customers is really the wrong
number of customers who have as way
harder to get your first customer,
but to eat your second year customer,
you know it's way easier to get your
hundred and second customer,
then your third customer,
massive easier part of the guys.
Who the hell wants to buy something from
you if you haven't sold something to
someone else.
You know people use social proof and you
aren't saying,
well I'm new and revolutionary and they,
well that's all well and good for you,
but just so damn wait,
I'm going to take the risk of being
wrong vibe and the product.
If I'd rather people buy it,
then I can say,
well these other hundred people bought
it.
So I thought it was okay,
which is a reasonable justification.
But otherwise they have to say,
well,
you know,
I wouldn't have gotten the lamp and just
a few exciting.
It's like,
yeah,
you're fire.
So,
so carbon is very,
very difficult to get away from zero now
and normally it's impossible because as
soon as you hit zero and we run into a
problem that you don't have when you
even have a $20 and the problem is you
cannot invest zero to making more money.
You're done.
You Stack up at zero,
you're done.
And so zeros were off number while we
keep playing,
someone walks away with all the money.
Yeah,
you've been complaining about the rules
of the game,
but you know the funny thing is people
will play even if they know they know
what the outcome's going to be.
One plutocrat walk away.
We called houses,
parks here and we'll track,
but then we were watching all this is to
recast the game and play once more.
The tables will often turn that my
client's hypothesis,
which I thought was very good one.
What's that?
That's what happens in society because
that's why they moved towards repletion.
That's kind of our society in some
sense,
which is that you play on the hate
logging off.
You could assume these are random and
trading game.
It's not exactly around the trading
game,
but you,
you've been Martin on quite nicely at
around three day.
What happens is eventually,
you know,
some people have oic everything and
almost every one stacks up and zero.
And the problem with zero is that you've
got nothing to lose if I don't flip the
damn board over and start a new game.
And that's especially true if your male
as their evening.
It's true if your males,
because may all need status and the
reason they need status is because
females don't like men with no status.
So that's a fundamental rule.
So the correlation between
male socioeconomic status and access to
me or is this roughly about 26 which is
a standard guy,
the high correlation for the social
sciences,
massive correlation.
You hardly see the only correlation I've
ever seen higher than that as the
relationship between inequality and male
on male homicide,
which is about 0.8 which is,
it comes from all of them.
So as any quality cram side,
men start to kill each other and they're
young men and the Carolina men and they
do it status disputes.
And then you have within race and it's,
it's,
it's you say read to me,
I see something,
bring it back.
We're trying to save face for,
tried to print up a,
the status soon if we're not careful
because we're impulsive because our
future is that right?
We have a short time horizon all we'd
gone to certain reputation.
It's like it's your big buddy and so you
ended up dead or maybe I ended up da,
it's a toss up.
And so what happens?
You get sharp for second degree murder.
There's not enough prosecutors to go
after you.
So company argued down to mass
slaughter.
You can argue self defense.
You're pointing to prison for three
years.
He served 18 months and when you come
out,
no blood in one messes with you.
Right?
Right.
That's a harsh economics.
The calculation.
I,
it's an effective one.
And so,
but one of the consequences of quality.
So we did research using this,
this,
this recalled the creative achievement
questionnaire.
And I developed with a student that by
name Shelly Carson,
when our is teaching in Boston and he
should be done point of popular nature.
Um,
when you're thinking about creativity,
there's two ways to think about it.
You can think about creativity as a
process.
You don't have to be how creatively can
you pay and that would be associated to
some degree with your Inq,
especially if their verbal Iq and also
with this trade is big five personality
traits don't as openness,
which is a fundamental,
fundamental,
deep,
vital,
ultimately recruited personnel on the
tree.
And basically people who are creative
are good at generating exemplars.
Either other category or between
Catholics in can you can,
I can test your creativity right back.
It's,
it's actually quite straight forward.
So for example,
if I go out to you guys to pull out a
piece of paper and write down his name,
where it says you could have that began
with the letter s in three minutes,
does the number of words you generated
would be correlated with your creative
capacity in about 23.4 and you think,
well that's not very high,
but actually that's higher than is
generated in both the 95% social science
studies.
So it's flaky.
Well,
small effects are just help a lot more
effective than you think for a variety
of reasons.
Partly because of the extreme is now.
Um,
and I can do a bandage off if I sat
down,
write down as many uses as you can for a
brick three minutes.
And then I sorted globally in terms of
how many uses you came up with,
but how comparatively rare you're
useless work compared to the rest of the
population that was being scored.
Now,
you know,
it would have to be sensible to happen
yet plausible use for a brick rarity and
fluency seem to make a lot of what
constitutes degree pivoted.
So that be measured for you?
Well but
and that's kind of normally distributed
like,
like intelligence.
We are interested in some something else
you've got straight ticket can be
defined in different ways.
So we are interested in creative
achievement accomplishment,
right?
So not only could you think creatively,
but you've actually produced something
in the world as a consequence.
And you can debate about which is the
better definition of creativity.
It doesn't matter.
You can have both definitions and
they're useful for different purposes
and we chose the greater achievement
definition because that was good.
We're curious about,
and so what we did was we thought we
thought as many dimensions as we thought
were reasonable in creative and so that
was like
dance music,
theater inventions,
cooking,
you know,
no architectural innovation,
um,
fiction writing,
nonfiction writing,
I don't remember all 13 but you get a
picture and then we had,
we,
we develop an eight point scale of
levels of achievement and we have them
generally by experts and then we rank
order them in terms of their being
probability.
So category zero bus,
I have don't training or talent in this
area.
And kind of [inaudible] was like,
well I have an reputation and so and so
did we have people fill out the Erin and
we go down to the distribution and what
we bought was pre don't yesterday you
should have,
that was before I do a premium.
Distributions were,
but he must've followed out and making
the scale in some stance because
everyone who's a social scientist
basically everything is normally
distributed.
It's just wrong.
Many things.
Our peritoneal distributed as a bring
out everything when people produce
creatively is distributed.
And that gets really,
really,
really important because you see,
one of the things that shows you is that
whatever's going on in the income
distribution doesn't just characterize
income distribution.
So you can't just blame it stupidly on
unfair social circumstance.
It's also the case that every society,
every study I was studying has a
peritoneal distribution of income.
Now how steep it is.
Dot varies to some degree.
As a consequence of things like social
policy,
that's very,
very difficult to get away from the
[inaudible] distribution.
With that,
we don't know how to get away from it.
That's,
that's the real truth about you don't
know how to get away from it anyways,
but that creative gene press here,
what we found was that I think it was
60% of people had a score of zero zero.
If they haven't done anything creative
in any of the 13 dimension,
look,
it's not that surprised that.
How many of you have written the book?
Well not.
And if you have written that,
you certainly hit publish it.
And if you didn't publish it and no
boss,
no one really wants,
it's pretty hard.
And then you write the minutes and
rejection ready first tried to get
publications like 99% I mean there's
like a million folks accomplished a year
as I think,
I can't remember.
It's like 2,500 the 10,000 copies or
something horrible like that,
you know it.
Steve became,
gets all the money
and this brings us to the reasons for
such thing.
So I have a friend who's his office and
he's,
he's not seeing his pain,
but he does three,
well,
he's written his the gear for Oh 20
years.
[inaudible]
has done a business,
but he's Brendan the edge of the radical
distribution.
He hasn't really hit the big time year,
but he's pushing most level is just
there.
They just start.
They just started like artists to start.
So we talked about this.
It's like we'll work it out.
What's going on here?
Why does all the money flow to like five
people?
And he said,
well think about this.
Think about geographically,
although in a strange manner,
think about real estate territory in
relationship to books.
And then think about going from the
airport and then think about going to
the airport bookstore and then think
about the best seller stand.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
down to 50,
the top five.
Everyone bought us them.
And then think,
well,
there isn't just one of those towns
and that's like 70% of the selling real
estate and territory.
And it's overwhelming dominated by
person up in the left hand corner.
Is it very often,
Steven King,
whose name everyone knows who's worth
everyone can predict,
makes the choice easy.
You know,
you're preoccupied,
man,
you're on a flight somewhere.
You don't want to say 10 minutes
figuring out what you're going to read
it like the plague
basis,
tens of billions of doors.
And that's how it goes for everything.
So here's another example.
So click about composers.
Um,
it turns out though
five composers,
Bach,
Beethoven,
and Mozart,
and Haydn
proposed the worst and they talked with
95% of the perform classical repertoire
composers DMP,
right?
And it's hard to composers [inaudible]
if you don't have to worry about
classical music you've been listening to
and any look at those,
those people's
useful conversations.
And what'd you find out is that 5% of
what they propose,
it's 95% of the playtime.
So it's like hardly any composers at all
composed all the music that everyone
listens to and God was hardly any of the
music that they can post.
And that's,
that's why.
And so when the economists,
this sort of thing called the matthew
principle,
which is an interesting nomenclature,
it's from US stealing by Christ in the
New Testament.
Don't think he has many economically
one of them.
It's a vicious,
vicious said,
some very vicious things in the New
Testament,
you know,
which is one of the things that need to
lend some credence in my estimation is
did you pick this?
Those things,
would it be
to those who have everything more will
be given from almost nothing.
Everything will be taken away.
It's like that's the matching principle.
That's the freedom principle.
Success breeds success and that's how
the world works.
What's the problem with that?
Zero you don't want to tell you too much
of a problem because it isn't like
actually zero but it's close to zero.
You know there was an article and yet
some report or just started to go and he
didn't do it.
It's overwhelming.
It's called like survey.
But you surveyed a bunch of people to
see what proportion of people could come
up with $500 in an emergency.
And the answer was in shockingly low
number of people or overextended and you
don't have any excess bunny at CAC.
So I'm going to leave when people who
were,
they weren't as zero,
which is a very rough place to be law.
You don't want people to stack up at
zero because what happens is that I,
one of the things that happens is that
the male violence,
let us start to call it.
So you think young man and he status
that they also need opportunity.
They also need something to aim for it,
right?
They need all of that.
And if they're in a place where the
inequality,
whenever any three steam,
it gets hard for them to move out of the
zero position.
And the district to do it.
Something to do it by any needs
whatsoever.
And so what seems to happen is that as
society becomes more and more on equal,
the pressure on young women and girls
and you can pageant well what sort of
young men and becomes viable the first,
and this is where you can have it up in
the other,
what would you call them?
Variables that predict violence.
Maybe impulsive guy,
maybe the guy who drinks too much,
take it.
The guy who was fond of swarm him
against the wall three or four times
when he was drunk when he was three and
damaged his brain.
You know,
anybody who's impulsive and liable to
his self,
the future,
it's hard to be even more hyper
motivated by in hopes of violence.
As adults,
we can call the client and they are
applying here and I'll be speaking out.
We've got,
like if you go back 80 95 you know,
in age 95 the average person in the
western world lived on $1 a day and you
want to take while the calder fucking
warrant more back then it's like,
no,
today's dollars.
But back then everyone had nothing thing
and have a few people have some,
I mean you can arrange that then didn't
live like any of you live now you've got
running water.
If you've got central eating,
you've got rely on shelter,
you've got an infinite amount of
information at your fingertips had every
moment it's like you're filthy rich,
you are filthy rich.
Money has bought everything that you can
have except sas because that's
comparitor.
So,
but the good thing to know because
otherwise he might think of yourself as
poor and if you're not,
you might be relatively core
but usually means you have to wait three
years to get the thing that the rich
guys have now.
But it's just not that big of a
catastrophe.
So anyways.
Okay.
So you is followed with societies with
regards to creative products tend to
tilt so that people stack up at the low
end.
And if you people start up idea and then
things start to be stabilized,
that's the big problem.
So like I tried this,
I bought this,
this was swell.
Societies run out there haven't been
trading game until it,
most people have zero and a few people
have everything.
And then the revolution comes in.
The board selected.
Everybody wants to start it.
Yeah.
So I'm assuming that if there's anything
left in the wrong,
right.
And so there's a Marxist flavor to that.
And of course mark's pointed out that
capital candidate to accumulate,
enhance with fewer and fewer people.
The thing he got wrong,
and this is an important thing to
understand,
is that although there is the 1% and
even born,
it was the one 10th of 1% who have
almost all the resources that the 1%
have,
right?
They that exists,
that it's always there,
but it's not the same people.
That's,
that's one of the things mark's got
seriously draw.
It's not the same people.
Most family fortunes only not for three
generations.
Right?
Because I don't know,
you guys should have money sometimes.
Did you keep it?
No problem.
And I the other people is it?
Yes.
[inaudible] all the way.
We're willing to Dole it out with just
that quickly because you have a lot of
money.
You just spent large homes,
money equally stupidly.
And let's for somebody who really knows
how to deal with money,
those people are really quite rare and
so family fortunes dispersed and very
rapidly and the typical fortune 500
company,
you only got us about 30 years.
So although the distribution is the way
that I describe it,
the constituent elements of the
distribution turnover quite rapidly.
So I think if you're,
what is it?
I think you'll have a 10% chance of
always that healthy stuff.
I think you have a 10% chance of being
top 1% for a piece,
one year of your life on average and a
40% chance of being in a top 10% for at
least one year on average.
So we know when people move up and down
throughout the life of,
another thing to keep in mind,
which is very important and no one ever
talks about this,
is that most of the reason that people
have money and said they're all right
because young people don't have any
money,
but they're young or old people and
we're waiting on in particular cause all
the alternate don't have over and have
most of the money right now because the
old man dies conveniently.
And
now you know the problem that people,
all my that role.
And so just the typical overs as me to
take credit me on the court and he got
to be,
well,
yes you could think about that yourself.
If you're young,
it's like,
okay,
you're now $20 million from afternoon 85
it's like,
what are you gonna take?
So,
you know,
to some degree it depends on how you
calculate.
Well,
right.
So,
okay,
so what's the point of all of that?
It all keeps us and it's actually a
fundamental problem.
And even if you're a conservative
person,
you might say,
well,
it's a fundamental problem because at
the inequality gets out of Canada to
Valerie and society starts cause you
stabilize.
And you know,
the one that conservatives,
Republicans say they're a cop on crime.
Progressive Conservatives for that
matter,
how dry.
It's like,
well what drives the risk by your crime?
They all are final homocide.
Let's say we know what it is.
It's inequality.
The correlation is,
like I said before,
gate,
it's all of it.
It's all of it.
That's what drives the status
competition.
And just interviewed Dr. Martin Daly
who's,
uh,
who's evolutionary psychologist,
staff mcmaster that being from this
place and
he,
you know,
he didn't know the Brown works with this
sort of research.
So I've been re released that in one
week and he wrote a book recently called
the killing to competition is very high
school.
He talks about being on the 11th it
says,
a rational strategy for uncertain
environment where there's a lot of chaos
and a lot of equality.
It's worth reading.
You know,
he's very strongly biological,
biologically oriented,
the evolutionary psychologists,
very,
very highly.
Incredibly.
My estimation,
but last two chapters deal with social
contributors to inequality and I don't
think that that is separately.
They're very powerful part of this book
because I don't think it deals with the
fundamental issue.
I'm trying to tell him,
cause I'm the medical issue.
If there's something going on here,
it's like a natural law.
There's producers,
there's wide disparity,
has an outcome.
Now the question is,
well,
what should we do about it and answer,
isn't it nothing?
Because if you let her drive him to his
conclusion,
then all hell breaks loose and yeah,
even if you're rich,
you think,
okay,
you're and you're down in Central
America,
even in Columbia.
Do you want to be rich in Columbia?
Well Great.
You have to.
You don't get to go outside instead of
inside the confines of your compound.
You're in a Ga.
Nice.
You know you're going to people in their
computers for family,
but fundamentally this jail,
he's got a huge house.
Hooray.
More clean as far as like
a fence around the barb wire.
You've got guards everywhere and can
help your kids having to go out.
They get kidnapped.
She was like,
are you rich?
Well,
I don't think so.
I haven't been Montreal.
I was poor.
You're speaking.
I just have a students,
you know,
students up a site map and I didn't
spend much time in my heart because I
wasn't looking place.
But Montreal,
peaceful,
right?
Great infrastructure,
great streets,
life.
You're safe.
There were three in the morning,
you can go anywhere in the city.
There's always something going on.
Often experiental cost public
essentially like in many European
cities.
Hell,
you're rich.
Well,
part of the reason you're reaching under
circumstances like that is because the
inequality hasn't gotten out of control.
And so you know,
we need to figure out how to define
wealth too,
because wealth is not just what you
happen to possess.
That might be sas and status is useful,
but status and wealth,
they're not the same thing.
Okay,
so now the issue is,
well,
there's a problem.
The problem is in quality goods are
unequally distributed and that's not
fair.
You know those additional problems that
go along with that.
Because one problem is is that if you
happen to be in the top 1%,
it's easy.
Your check is your from your children's
who also quite off the socioeconomic
live.
Now it's not as easy as people think and
there's a reasonable probability that
you'll fall and some of it is actually
due to intelligence because it turns out
that on average intelligence people have
more money than unintelligent people,
which hard becomes a surprise and
conscientious people have more money
than I'm conscientious people,
which also hardly comes as a surprise.
And if you haven't become as your
parents and you're more likely,
if you can tell yourself not as
intelligent as them,
cause you addressed to the me,
even even the unequal distribution of
intelligence sorts itself out across
time.
But you show up there,
you still have what you might describe
as a technically unfair advantage.
Okay,
so you've got a distribution problem,
you got to technically unfair
opportunity problem and it's reasonable
to point those up and that's what the
left does,
right?
That's what the leftover food,
it's functioning properly.
It says,
look,
we've got to keep the day,
I mean,
quality the Gini Coefficient,
let's say you're got to give you the
call.
He flattened out because we won't have a
civil society without it.
And we'll meet people at the blog who
could be productive and useful and we
will get an opportunity and then we will
get to enjoy all the cool things they
might have made were invented.
And that's,
that's why I'm,
that's a good point.
And you know,
when people say,
yeah,
but if you flatten out the damn
distribution too much,
then you remove people's incentives and
you don't want to do that too much.
And it's like,
yeah,
that's right.
True.
So you've got truth,
a truth be and o questionnaire as well,
which true ratings.
Right?
Well that brings us to the next one.
So I'm going to talk to some things
about right,
but here's what I'm going to tell you
some things about last week.
So the first thing I'm going to do is to
tell you about why people are like that.
And we've even,
and other labs [inaudible] labs first.
In fact,
um,
have you investigated the relationship
between the fundamental biological
tempered,
what's included intelligence and
political?
That's called a viewpoint.
It's better to get an opinion or
attitude,
the idea of a viewpoint.
It gives you,
see,
when you guys look at the world,
you don't see the world and just see
that tiny little fragment of the world
that you find valuable,
right?
If a rose to complicate it,
and I can know how many of you have seen
the famous invisible gorilla video,
but you know,
there's a bunch of people playing
basketball team 0.3 of them wanting and
what I craved them,
it has the bouncing balls back and forth
between them.
You're supposed to count the number of
times the way t passes basketball.
They feel a visual screen.
These,
these six people,
they're dense around this.
The best of all,
you're counting,
you're thinking,
you're pretty damn smart.
It just,
and you can count
stands the screen and beats his chest
for like 15 seconds and says songs off.
And then the experimenter baskets,
you did you notice anything strange and
was saying no.
And he says,
well,
how many passes did you say?
16 and you think,
ah,
and then he says,
did you see the gorilla?
And he'd say,
what are luck?
Or talk to them.
You say what her role.
And so then you rerun the tape and sure
enough quick power palatable ran
hundreds girl right in the of the screen
you are just not very bright.
Three blind.
We are so large and the points were so
mine.
It's so focused in know we're kind of
like a panel on a piece of paper.
You know human consciousness is likable.
The ball point portal that Canon,
it's writing but it's just barely making
contact.
Yeah.
What's enough to write and move on,
which is not trivial but that's how
focused we are and we're focused on the
things that we find before.
But then question,
yes,
why don't we find the things we find the
portal and pardon and ask her.
That means at least in part Kimber
kimber filters for you.
So for example,
an example,
if you're high in openness,
you're going to be attracted to duty.
You'd be attracted.
Hispanics.
Could he trapped with ideas?
If you're an extrovert and it's like the
whole world is a part of it and you're
the entertainment if you're,
their audit is like key things that are
game away from him cause you're
agreeable.
It's relationships.
You want to take care of things,
you want a formal relationships.
If you're conscientious,
it's like an eagle lake view,
a heat away due to the relative
industries orderly.
And then not only did they,
does that cover your attitudes,
but it also filters things for you.
So you see the world through your
temperament.
You can filter news through your
temperament,
right?
And so well part of that is because
there's different niches in the world.
It's like,
you know,
maybe you're an entertainer is when
people like to fight,
you're part of the city you can be
relied on.
So when people ask you to help them
move,
which is the going from,
you know,
maybe you were agreeable.
So you know,
if someone needs to have a talk about
something that's bothering them,
that you're there,
maybe you're disagreeable or there's
someone wants to blunt truth,
then you'll come and talk to you.
And so these are all places that you can
fit in the social structure and in the
world.
So that's where I lose that 30 again,
you know,
more power to it.
It's great people come equipped in the
world with different tools and the tools
allow them to do different things.
And that's what diversity is.
It's real diversity,
not that idiot diversity that was
showing us
right in place of real diversity.
All right,
so are your,
the way you are now,
you know Tara is high character,
you know it can be both.
So for example,
if you have a child who's high in
neuroticism,
let's say,
and you can tell if you have a child
left out because there more fussy,
it's hard to calm them down.
They started or easily to a noise.
They're more,
you know,
in more cautious of strangers.
If something new,
the famous study by drove the get use
robots to test kids.
See how they describe it that way.
Precisely.
He wrote all of a sudden Ronnie in his
room with these reflect to your rules,
maybe wave line slash sheet and somebody
can use the extra virgin.
Not at all my courses and just,
you know,
interact with the devil and the more
timid ones with hard to be heard.
Your parents,
mothers,
no man.
And that was adamant as early a six
months.
Now what Kagan found was that if the
people who have what he called inhibited
children were diligent in encouraging
them to get out and explore the world,
that their level of negative emotion
could move towards normalization over a
number of years.
But they never became truly fearless
people.
You know,
you could modify.
And of course if you have a kid like
that and you miss,
treat them and make the regarding to
very uncertain and you take away all the
security from them,
then you can turn them into a complete
neurotic wreck and they'll never
recover.
And so,
and so,
you know,
the same applies for extroversion and at
the same applies for conscientiousness
and agreeableness.
These things are deeply,
deeply rooted in people.
Now you can move them around to some
degree,
but first of all,
why would you,
except maybe it's nice to have a kid
feeling more emotionally stable.
Um,
it's okay if that diversity exists and
it's useful to know that it can be
easily automated.
That's part of you.
The reason that's useful to know if,
because one of the things that you want
to know,
if you want to be successful,
find a damn job that suits your
cameraman because it's easier than
changing their temperament to suit the
job.
So if you're is meredith and I had made
the commotion,
I would say say owes no problem.
And if you're like our radical
extroverts,
like computer programming,
probably not.
You're going to be the guy who's
wandering around chatting to all the
other programmers and annoying the hell
out of them.
The,
they're introverted and they can be
conscientious as well.
They want to do is be alone in the
border until go away like joe you.
So,
okay,
so back to holy text.
Well,
it turns out that temperament predicts
political belief very nicely.
Now at the level of only predicting,
say party affiliation or voting
behavior,
you can give up 10% of the various
political weight,
which doesn't sound like much,
but just lansing to throw the election,
right?
Because you know the hinge on time,
90 markets the best presses up the u s
but if you do a detailed analysis of
people's political beliefs,
so you differentiate how much farther
than you you're voting behavior,
you can get like 30% of the variance.
It starts to get to viciously powerful,
powerful enough to make the assumption
that the primary determinant of
political belief is temporal and the
primary each other,
the cameraman is biology and so you're
biologically pre disposed to be whatever
card you are.
Now you might say,
well,
what about the well known where young
people tend to be more liberal,
less bleeding in young people or do
people tend to be in a more
conservative?
Part of the reason for that is if people
get more conscientious as they age and
so that it doesn't destroy it up.
I bought the system at all.
Now the reason that's useful to know,
he said,
you know,
if you're aware laughy and you're
talking to someone who's right way,
you're not just talking to some blind 88
you to see the obvious truth.
You're talking to someone who's
different than you and there's reasons
that they're given.
It happens at different niche and occupy
a different edge.
And that's a real niche.
It's real.
So here's an example.
Are you trying to predict
entrepreneurial behavior for a long time
learned to do it or it's successful and
he's nor obvious who entrepreneurs are?
You know,
are they the same as executives?
They say there's managers.
So they have to say is an industry,
is it the same as your first two
professors are artists?
None of that.
It's all true though.
They're the same as ours.
So why don't you drivers are creative
people.
They're high in openness.
Now what that means is they're pretty
damn good at coming up with eye gaze and
moving sideways and reading inside.
Cause if they have to,
but they generally aren't very good at
all.
Everyone companies,
what do you want to run?
The company is someone who's
conscientious and conscientious people.
They'll do what they're supposed to do.
If they know what it is,
they're not jumping all over the place.
They want to track to walk out.
Right?
So if you have someone installing gas
pipes where there's not supposed to be
any leaks cause otherwise they explode.
You want some obsessive conscientious
got who wants to get with exactly right.
You don't want some Korean guy who wants
to make like a coach
consultant.
Entrepreneurs are afraid of him.
They're liberals and the managers and
administrators on the conservative yet.
And so you need liberal place to start
companies to be creative and you need
conservative types to run.
And so that's kind kinda nice.
You know,
how many creative types need compared to
how big managerial types has the same
problem as how many fingers do you need
in the political sphere versus how many
conservatives and actually conveys it
depends on circumstances.
Okay,
so now we'll go into more deeply.
So heres the predictors,
the fundamental predictors of political
belief up.
Just a little conservative for now.
I say that just left and right.
I'll tell you about the flooding from
prep types of,
but we'll just say the conventional left
to right distribution,
the right waivers are low in openness.
That's the creativity dimension,
right?
They can't think of very many uses for a
break.
If you ask them,
he use this,
well you can't do
[inaudible] [inaudible] I can change
anything.
Creative guy,
he's going to get all sorts of like it's
a hack,
you know,
and so on.
And so conservatives are low in openness
and high in conscientiousness,
conscientiousness fractionated into
industriousness in order,
but he does and they're particularly
high in orderliness.
So that's the conservative,
not a very creative or and you know,
confection.
Here's some other things.
Let's say I'm ordering traditional
hierarchical kid dutiful hi candidate
here,
tactical,
conventional,
narrow,
predictable.
Now some of those things,
especially if you're labeled,
you say none of that for us.
Traditional hierarchical,
Jill doing it full or orderly.
It's like,
well do you want things in order or not?
You know what,
the traffic lights working one of the,
his throw one time so to speak.
You are with things to do what they're
supposed to do.
So like while that the ordinary people
out or do you want to go do something
exciting to get the hell away from them?
They have to have point now you could
get to order and that's for sure and you
can get to anything.
That's the thing is that there's kickass
cookies at the end of the temperamental
distributions to neurotic dog.
Good.
Too conscientious.
You give a no on the obsessive side.
Maybe develop an eating disorder,
too agreeable everyone.
I'm sacrificing myself for everybody.
It's like team,
you're resentful and bitter because it
can't stand up for yourself
to friend prison
incarceration.
It's like William Straight.
If you're bad,
you go off the rails because people make
loud.
We want to be happy.
He's like,
well,
how many do you want to be
impulsive and there's no trace of it.
Someone who's an addict is they only
money?
Why?
Because the world is such a wonderful
place.
You find.
I just find that happy people are
impulsive as a year.
Notice if you're one of those people who
like to drink because it energizes you
and you know who's probably 10% of the
people in your life that it's like a
dream to be energized because most of
you just to relax,
but some of you get energized.
It's like to make good decisions when
you're in that habit is no,
happiness means rapport.
You can grab Napkins,
you content.
Sometimes that's what good idea,
but sometimes it's read it knowledge.
So don't be thinking then you know you
can't get to happen.
It's like he'd get ready to be to
happen.
So you know they're,
they assess it.
Any virtue that becomes a virus and
that's where I began with the lows and
the damn conservatives have to talk.
Right?
Okay.
So if you think you got a company,
you want to figure out how many
advantages versus how many entrepreneurs
who need and that's what that is.
And some circumstances there isn't a
balance.
You can't say,
well you need like 40% free people and
60% conscientious me.
And the reason you can't say that it's
because the environment is a giant snake
and it continues.
It's giant eternal surfer and you're on
it's back and you don't know which way
it's going to move.
If you fall off and fall off the left
side of you die off right side,
you die and still run.
You want to do is stay approximately in
the middle.
And so when you need is one side
pulling,
pulling.
And what you hope is that by holding
each other,
you say in the name of the damn snake
and then you think about how can you
decide a pole and the answer is low,
but then maybe you killed the other
person or they kill you and they need
them.
As it turns out,
or maybe your dad,
that doesn't seem like a very good
solution again,
that that's actually the frog you're
trying to solve.
And so you can,
you can,
you can become slaves to the other side.
You can impress the other side.
You can find with the other side or,
or you can talk,
okay,
that's the alternative.
You can talk and you're going to talk to
those annoying people who aren't white
kidney.
And one of the advantages to those who,
even people who aren't like,
you know,
pleadings,
you don't know
all those people.
You get along so well,
you're already like with you,
you can't remember anything from them.
They just know what the same thing as
you know.
No,
that's fine.
Do you know everything you need to know?
So how do you know?
Where do you want?
Give me whether or not you know
everything you need to know who suffer.
So what you're suffering and you are.
Then I would suggest you probably have
something to learn because maybe if you
learned that you wouldn't have to do
that.
Why?
But they're not going to say,
well,
since you were a new mobile soccer so
much,
you should talk to someone who knows the
things you don't because then we'll try
some things you don't know and then you
won't suffer so much.
And an ask the purpose of free speech.
Okay,
so let's retracted with it now.
You wouldn't use her problems.
Well obviously.
Why don't you just tragic and shorter.
We have a problem.
Poor people have problems.
Rich people have problems.
What are the things?
It's actually quite sad about socialists
and perhaps about catalyst as well.
And both Roddick can overestimate the
degree to which money can solve
fundamental existential crawls.
It actually can't own install.
This is quite clear on that too.
Why don't you make enough money so
you're not suffering from absolute
[inaudible],
which means that bill collectors chasing
you around the get your life miserable.
Then additional button on we call it.
And so when you get that baby at anybody
out to work in class,
they go higher than that.
Yeah.
We might still be resentful because
there are legal or Richard and you.
But did you get more money?
Doesn't help.
Why?
Well why would you still die?
Maybe you ain't no longer.
Maybe they can help you in catch later
for an extra year.
Divorce.
Well it doesn't help me get along with
your wife.
It doesn't help you necessarily get
along with your kids.
No,
it doesn't prevent him from dying or the
of various diseases doesn't make it my
similar while sometimes lots of times it
doesn't.
Once you solve your basic economic
problems cause she do,
just to repeat,
what does he have running water,
shelter
and access to the information you're up.
Stitches you can be to except to the
comparitor your basic problems.
Our soul.
Again,
the 90th percentile and maybe you want
to hit the nine ninth to like one or two
of you,
but most of the problems I used to be
saul.
Okay.
Anyways,
people find problematic,
right?
Life is suffering.
That's a fundamental rule.
The rule is exactly her job.
She transcendence,
which is a very straight,
very surreal to say,
why do you think
here's how animals,
here's the equipment,
you're not stupid hunting as
unbelievably intelligent.
It's not the same kind of intelligence
that we have.
So the mosquitoes I'm riding the giant
circuit to,
it's flipping everything.
Some of the ceos are talking about the
dog and so how do we manage that?
Well there,
I mean is made and cruise a whole slew
of mosquitoes.
No patch if it was feels or at all died
except for one I didn't know [inaudible]
you just keep going and so many,
many mosquito eggs,
art of mosquitoes way of thinking,
right?
Because what the mosquito was doing is
producing small parents.
I was south,
which of those are going to survive?
They're slightly different.
And then you know,
her wonderfulness white,
he said,
why don't scale.
And you go back and tell you why we need
the deep and I need a yard.
So mosquitoes produce as much as areas
of themselves and they're,
most of them died.
And then one mosquito lives.
That's how they propagate themselves
through time.
So
human beings the opposite thing.
[inaudible]
very deep,
very number limit wrap up his or our
salt water into educated.
And we do that because our children are
capable of producing,
bearing sometimes sat in front of me.
So you know,
you play,
did you get [inaudible] happen?
The Bar,
you can send me out to her off that.
And in part because you know,
give him a paid promotion but you're not
there.
So that's what an idea is.
An idea is I'm avatar you and moral and
even think about this from an
evolutionary perspective because the
prefrontal Cortex,
which is the whole of your capacity to
think abstractly,
grows the lower court.
Yes.
An order for Texas to thinking that
enables you to voluntarily [inaudible]
world.
And so what you do when you fake is
generate,
I'm strapped versions of yourself,
test them in a fictional environment,
figure out which ones are stupid and
likely to die and then don't act those
out
then at that than others.
But nonetheless,
the technical person doesn't act out
their stupidest ideas.
And so we internalize the Darwinian
process.
We think we pretty spare minutes of
ourselves.
We killed them all for ourselves.
And then when you're coming out,
the ones that you take your most likely
to survive pretty damn smart.
So yeah,
chaos.
But he has limitations.
Limitations.
Well,
we talked about one
camera.
You know,
if you're a local person,
phoned openness.
This is one of the things that drives me
crazy about conservatives.
So concerns are blind to bub.
They're so fun.
Like I remember Harper,
this is going to be one of the dumbest
things he said.
He was talking about harvest.
He makes sense each hold like limousine
artists that were
what?
Sponging off the public purse.
You know these French artists,
it's like there's like three rich
artists to Canada,
right?
The probability that you're going to get
Richard as an artist is so low that I
didn't know.
You're like,
you're like,
I'm you.
You're like you.
You're like an accident.
If you're,
if you're an artist and he would make
enough money to survive,
it's impossible.
There's no rich artists.
So,
but the conservatives,
they don't think,
they don't see that because they don't
see the contribution that artists make.
You're blind to it.
And so I can give you exactly what,
how open people work and how they
contribute to the public good.
If he had a large city like Wilson,
you,
you don't look at these trashy areas
that are kind of cool and the old people
go there and the reason they go there is
because that's the frontier.
And that's what,
when people go to the frontier,
the Korean type status,
their niche is the frontier.
There's for all tiers everywhere.
There's four in science.
Does Frontier [inaudible] frontier as
literature.
There's frontiers in cities and the
frontier in the cities where there's
other Lemar chaos then order.
But there's potential artistic type.
Sniff that out.
And I as part of,
if they can only afford rent there,
don't just go hang out with your
neighbor.
They go,
hey hon and rough name because they
think,
hey this,
they can sniff out
galleries and maybe we start to go to
coffee shops and then they start to do
cool things and it starts to get cold.
And then the legs helping people who are
still kind of open go here and hay out.
They think that's cool.
And then the entrepreneurial capital was
tied to start to notice and they start
the road safe and they have a place
judge requires the artistic chased,
the Reiki.
They don't have anybody cause they know
how to
improve some of the carbon for the city.
And so that's what creative people do.
Beauty has an incredible,
incredible value.
Think about Europe.
You came,
it's a blend.
Two as a people or cities,
there's the garden,
they're European cities.
Men,
like were you saying about the hundreds
of millions or billions of dollars that
those dams,
European step in Fargo cities,
you think about the return on investment
that they gathered,
you know,
I mean places like France and Spain have
more tourists then people all the time
because people are going there from all
over the world,
bathing beauty.
Also,
it's useful to talk to them open types
and do appreciate what they have Prof.
So anyways,
you're blinded by your camper
conservatives camps and beauty,
uh,
liberal types,
especially if they're low in order to
get us,
they can't see the value of diligence or
duty.
So I ran it the right fingers,
traditional,
hierarchical,
the other gym,
beautiful,
orderly,
hygienic,
puritanical,
conventional,
narrow and predictable.
The hygienic and puritanical thing that
you could get up and down that's
associated with disgust,
sensitivity.
There aren't really,
people are very sensitive to the US and
part of the reason that the hyper
conservative types are exclusionary is
because they build walls around
themselves to prevent contamination.
And we'll get back to that.
And there's reasons for that.
It's not arbitrary prejudice all the
way.
It can be arbitrary prejudice.
Unfortunately it's more complicated that
left fingers radical fluid,
mercurial,
Carolyn's chaotic,
unsanitary and promiscuous,
12th of and he's doing it depends on
your perspective.
It's a little harder on the old sexually
transmitted disease.
You know
how many people did age killed?
About 400 million.
I think that's a fairly high increase in
pain,
I would say so it's not like there's
nothing serious at the bottom of these
various is there's something damn
serious at the bottom of them and
there's real room for flora of have
informed opinions.
All right,
so you got the conservative tax low in
openness,
high in conscientiousness.
You want something done to their people
to do it.
They're liable.
They're traditional or hierarchical.
You have Velma structures,
their guilt,
native soldiers.
It's very brilliant,
corrupt military accomplishment.
Conscientiousness is a good grip crew of
race.
It's a good predictor of manager of the
bakery.
The next test doesn't predict creative
production,
openness.
Openness is actually slightly need.
If he call me and we started ticketing
product,
did it as far as we can tell because
sorry,
support,
mostly diligent rather than their
artistic the sciences and dealt with
through the process.
You know,
it's,
it's a fact that you can grind it out,
which just part of why it's so damn
powerful.
So they're gonna say,
well why,
why would openness and conscientiousness
go together?
You political belief because they're not
coordinating those,
there's traits.
It doesn't seem to be any real reason
why they should clump together to
determine the clinical to be turn in
political opinion viewpoint.
I was thinking about this a lot and I
thought,
well,
you know,
the older people they like,
they like the Jack in the box,
jump out the blocks and if they don't
want the box to stay closed,
they want all the possibility and the
box does spring out.
And so they can do cool things with it.
And if you're go to conscientiousness,
they're going disgust,
sensitivity.
So we are a character of borders between
things.
So on the one hand,
they're not afraid of the absence of
borders.
And I'm have to be like the exciting
things that happens to the barbers are
transgressed against and I were
thinking,
well,
that pump conservative types,
they're high in conscientiousness.
It's like they like orders that's
ordered.
They like to be protected from
contamination and the overall in this,
so they don't get any thrown with the
Jack in the box,
jumps up the box.
They just think that they should stay in
the box for long it long.
And then I thought,
well that's interesting.
You know I mentioned that works every
single level of analysis.
It's like the conservative types,
like the border around concepts,
three main title identities,
sexual identity,
it's holes,
private property towels,
provinces,
states.
I thought,
well that's what happened in the last
election.
That's what happened.
The trial because what did he say?
Let's feel the wall.
It's about the borders.
Well that's what's happening to Europe
to it's the borders.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's exactly right.
That's what politics is about.
It's about borders between things.
And if the fundamental argument is,
well,
she's worse.
She opened her clothes.
And the answer that is,
it depends on the circumstances because
we're driving and johnny sermon,
Kevin Number,
which weeks where you turn.
And sometimes here's what happens.
If you open the borders,
grace,
let's say you woke up from accidentally.
So this is what happened to the native
Americans.
They are warriors,
let's say,
and his family.
And she'll go,
well,
you know the Spaniards and showed out
for off on.
We have the social side,
particularly rough time for the native
Americans.
And you know,
we conquered the entire territory.
But no man,
they had horses and armor and the need
for having a crisis at the time.
And so,
you know,
that was bad luck,
but that wasn't the real problem.
The real problem is that the Spanish
were filled with the absolutely filthy,
like all the European city dwellers of
the time packed.
And can you,
he's living with animals,
Roy.
The disease developed immunity to
diseases.
So yeah,
when we got small parts,
but to die,
they book very horrible for chicken pox
and we lived through the,
and you can make her mom's like healthy.
You were,
but you were well armed against
pathogens.
Well,
not the North Americans,
not the Americans.
Not at all.
There's hardly any disease here.
So the Spanish showed up,
not even 5% of the native American
style.
Right.
Think about that.
So many of them died and the puritans
showed up,
which was a long time out with Hispanic,
showed up.
The native Americans were happy to see
them to the Internet,
going to be able to take off their
crops,
guessing like the third of European sky.
Yeah.
I thought it was a border issue to break
because the racks came in off the shifts
and it sailed somewhere else.
30% of the European startups,
black player.
Well,
that's not good compared to 95% all in
the borders to see what the hell
happens.
It's dangerous.
You know,
liberal types.
No,
no,
not all.
Wonderful.
Now the liberals will say,
well,
I'll just hold on a minute.
It's like,
yeah,
there's some danger in close quarter in
open borders,
but they won't say that because they
can't see that.
But if they were sensitive and we'd say,
yeah,
we buy the argument that there's danger
in open borders.
I think of all the drivers just soak the
borders between everyday was like,
yeah,
fluency and thought.
You here to talk about the relationship
with the fluency in thought and the
ability to think divergently and
creativity.
It's like,
Whoa,
become old and borders between things,
between concepts,
between people,
between towns.
We're not going to have any new ideas,
but I'm going to get anything new
happening.
We're hungry to go find a stranger from
another culture and welcome them in and
find out what they held her up to a
train and come and get all the cool
stuff.
That's a problem.
If we caused the borders to type it,
then what's going to happen is we're
going to stay that safety regarding to
stand to say,
Bro,
look the same.
We talk the same and then the damn snake
is going to move and every single one of
us is going to fall off.
It's like,
yeah,
well sort of service and gavel open the
borders staff and the liberals say
closed borders debt and the right,
both of them are right.
That's the thing.
They're both right and that's why we
need to talk to each other.
You see,
because we can't out.
So figure out how to stay on the
secretary of the snake without talking
to them.
Now you've got your biases,
your cognitive biases that are built
into you,
and so you're blind to all solve the
world and so you're going to sit down
and fit.
If you're thinking you actually break
yourself into avatars,
cards,
and you give all those appetizers,
the voice,
and then you let them how she knows and
the woman,
where did she go?
So even when you were thinking you're
basically engaged in dialogue,
it's just what you're doing it
internally.
But you have limits on that because
unless you're very good at figuring
that,
you probably don't want it because
people aren't going to do the thinking
there.
They're really good at jumping into
predetermined to conclusions and very
bad thing because it's hard to think
it's annoying.
It's just stressful that it's
technically difficult.
It requires training.
You have to be able to write,
you have to be able to think clearly.
I feel to formulate an argument you have
to read.
It's like it's really hard to think and
sold as much as could just fly over your
built a priori temperamental soldiers,
which is what people do to to a great
degree.
But when I say you can figure to some
degree,
well good.
So that means there's forms of death and
misery then you can avoid with some
degree of,
of you tell them,
but you're full of biases.
You're going to miss this.
This is part of why married people live
longer and you never narrative someone.
They're annoying.
You could think differently than you,
but that's so helpful if you listen to
them because they can have two brains.
Two brains actually get you through the
royal families of one grade if the
brains are communicating and if they
have some differences,
right,
because then you're not just producing
the same.
So if I open myself up to someone else
and talk to them it in dialogue,
then be correct.
The errors in my thinking and then
perhaps less less chance of suffering
and dying and so the reason that you
have to engage your Donald Donald's
because that lifts you out of your a
parochial view and helps you clarify the
world and clarify how to act in the
world with all these different people
that you have to get along with.
That's part of it,
but also to survive just in the world
and make a little sidebar.
Here is something that we can talk about
more in future.
I have been thinking about those damn
postmodernists
pernicious,
horrible idea is true that any text has
an infinite number of potential
interpretations and then therefore
there's no way of determining which
interpretation is correct.
Now the problem with that interpretation
because it in some perverse sense is
true because there are so many
phenomenon the delay themselves before
you even the world that you can construe
it involved in different ways,
but here's for the wrong.
They say you can interpret it that same
way.
Therefore you're traveling the world in
a way because the world is like a text.
If it has multiple potential donation,
but looking for
some of those interpretations will kill
you.
Someone goes into her,
patients will make you suffer.
Some of those are patients will make
people around you suffer.
Some of those interpretations will make
people hate you.
people refuse to cooperate with you.
So you say,
well there's this multiplicity of
interpretations,
but it's constrained by the necessity of
preserving yourself.
Preservative,
dyadic relationships,
preservative,
progams,
social,
social contexts.
So happy in a manner.
So pursuing your own selfish interests
definitely stabilized old damn game.
And also when you act in the actual
world,
it doesn't slap you so hard across the
face that you perish.
And so yes,
there are home with the DMP
certifications,
but there is a very tiny fraction of
them that actually have any functional
utility.
So I'm the runs completely be the
nihilistic argument related to
multiplicity.
That's at the basis of postmodernist.
They know what's at the basis of
postmodernism cause that's why they
turned the Marxism Dornier themselves.
Because you can't do anything if you're
a postmodernist because there's no
proper solution.
So anyways,
back to free speech.
You have to think because if you don't
think you die but you're too stupid to
pick rod,
you are,
you have to talk to other people because
they tell me why you're stupid.
And then if you listen,
you're not quite so stupid.
Now you go and die for often.
So that's the bottom line.
And they might say,
well who should I talk to them and
answered as well.
If you talk to people that you agree
with,
you don't burn anything cause they are
to think the same way you do.
And unless you're 100% correct and I
will be very,
very hesitant about including that.
If you're still suffering and I her 100%
correct,
then you've got to go find out an
entity.
Have you talked to,
because maybe they'll point something
out to you that you seriously,
seriously,
seriously needs to know.
And so you know,
our culture of Western civilization,
let's say roughly speaking,
it's a good culture.
You know,
like I'm the utopian,
it's got its problems.
If you compare it to a hypothetical
utopia is hell on earth except we're
not.
Hypothetical.
Utopia actually tries to manifest itself
because Ben didn't find out what really
is.
But that is how you compare a society.
What you do is you take a society and
say,
well how are we good compared to like
other societies and actress?
Well,
you won't be hampered skill you guys
like that.
They could go wherever they want and so
when they go,
well they go to that tiny handful of
countries that has the lacy that's
tightly associated with free speech.
Why?
Because basically we can solve our
problems that we have.
We don't have any,
we got a loss,
but we can solve a why cause we figured
something out.
We figured out that there's nothing more
important than free speech because
that's what thinking is.
That's the logos that sits at the bottom
of our culture,
right?
The divine word that transforms chaos
into order continually and you are
taking half,
not individually precisely.
Although you do as an can,
participate in conversation,
communication with other soul and also
sad you straight.
If you're not afraid,
then you suffer and die and so when
people around,
because lots of people laying that down.
But if you're nodding at that end,
if you're ready to get it done,
you should really
be hearing is it the task stuffy and
where the work to bring it to a hall,
making her song case for that.
I think it's a terrible case.
I think it's a profoundly flawed chase
because it's predicated on the idea that
you've already done everything you could
to improve phase.
So I would say well before you transform
yourself into the ultimate judge of
being,
you should try to get your act together
to some degree and see if you can draw
things around.
You can render your final judgment and
how you do that.
Well,
what does that mean?
What do you no,
no,
no.
That's where things aren't right that
sex,
the other and go on as well for you and
I'm going to work for your family.
It could be,
or your community or your country or the
world
you can be trying to solve.
Then he asked us a couple,
are you touring assault?
That's not the right person,
right?
First two years are trying to solve them
with all your heart and mind and soul.
And that is no,
I spent six hours a day wasting time,
which is pretty much standard.
And you got no right to say anything at
all except started getting bacteria.
And so it's time for everyone,
right?
That's the right response is that
orients you property towards Ba and then
being humble,
knowing that you don't have your act
together.
Then maybe you open your eyes when you
say todd,
just more things.
I don't know what.
I'm stupid.
And there's some people who are
different from me.
Maybe if I talk to them,
listen to mostly cause you wouldn't
believe when people will bloody will
tell you if you listen to them.
It's just absolutely unbelievable
experience listening to people.
Cause I'm a clinical psychologist cause
it's like there's a dos nfc.
No.
Once you get the problem,
88 theological presuppositions and they
start talking about the reality that
they're actually in contact with.
They're endlessly revealing and remark
and you learn.
And you mentioned listening to what a
good deal that is because you're not
very smart and he was suffering.
And so you know,
if you could learn something from
someone,
especially someone different than you,
it's like wow,
it's a good day math in sixth grade.
Okay.
So,
okay,
so
back to the left lane.
Well,
right.
What do you are,
you know,
disintegrated or I don't pick up after
themselves
because sometimes we need that.
And then so there were no,
just a sec conservatives.
Well,
I know they've got the blinders on,
man.
They're just not that exciting this page
and make it a little discriminatory.
They like things to stay where they are,
so they're not that much fun to party
with.
You want something done?
Well,
they're equal and you know,
they're hauling the people that you want
to be false sterilized,
hypodermic needles,
for example.
So let's appreciate political
distribution and let's understand that.
You need to say on the dark in there.
I'm snake.
Okay,
so I'll close with a little more
elaboration on the left.
The main rationale for free speech,
that was something like free speech is
being used by fascists
or as far as politically correct.
Radical left is conservative.
Everything because he used to impress
the oppressed.
They got a one size fits all solution.
It's corporate intellectually and it's
pathological world and that's part of,
it's just too easy.
I the side of the oppressed that needs
to be a good person.
It's like,
you know,
first of all,
what makes you think you're on the side
of your pressed?
Really,
you really dare to claim
it's not so easy to be on the side of
the deal press.
It takes a hell of a lot of work to be
on the side of the oppressed and you can
do sergeants in the face of people that
you think you,
hey,
that's not on the side.
You'll laugh.
That's no matter to say,
why am against poverty?
[inaudible]
oh,
you a word.
If there was some controversy company
come to visit,
there's a little article in the
newspaper.
Somebody who was your professor said was
reprehensible.
I was making the space on safe,
but you can tell
presuppositions and get down to the,
and so
I tweeted out with top off the linfield
college to violate some safe space.
It's a satirical show.
They got wind of it.
That's a pretty vicious tweet.
Doesn't matter the venue,
I mean serious
of all the people who should be in favor
of free speech,
it shouldn't be the people who are
hypothetically on the side of the people
press.
Why the radical left precept position is
everything's a hyper dominant patriarchy
and the people at the park,
all the power.
Okay,
well then the people at the top,
whenever they want,
they own the newspapers,
they own TV stations.
They only advertisements.
They only corporations.
They can say wherever they want,
whenever
they don't need to be protected.
Obviously they have a little,
and I'm speaking from a logical
framework,
right?
Well who needs for connection if they
want to speak for obviously the people
who are up the water.
Okay,
so let's review the evidence.
Social movements of the 20th century.
What's the way mantra,
speak truth to power?
That means you've got,
you have to be able to speak to speak
out and hypothetically not going to be
in power.
Things like,
hey,
that's a lot of what you've got on half
my core aid,
but why people are you kidding?
He's got a lot of courage.
That guy and he's conquered.
Know he's,
he's a show both.
He started my butt.
That's version of vital
comedians,
like definitely got Walter play because
they're good at,
they're good at social critics.
You know,
so far you got to speak truth to power.
Well then you better be able to speed
that.
That's the fundamental issue.
So,
okay,
so you're left your,
you want to slap it on the inequality,
the Rhogam and you think,
well Geez,
I'm going to be able to talk about this
at least.
And then you think,
well let's,
let's restrict free speech and many
things.
Here's a,
here's a lesson from the military.
If you make a weapon here,
meb,
how's it been 15 years?
So you know,
the logical conclusion to that is
something like kind of be slightly carry
both which weapons you made it and so
what's the lesson for their free speech?
Trump haters.
It's like
you guys are the ones who think that
everyone else has to power.
You start restricting free speech,
which you're doing what you're doing it
radically,
continually,
no stall.
It's like you think for a moment.
If those people who have the power and
the,
let's say the crooked people who have
the power,
just to clarify it,
you just take that,
they're not going to get a lot better at
that than me real quick here.
So glad they're naive and it's doing
even funny.
They're going to be those.
Every single one he used to oppress free
speech is going to be a bat.
You would force it.
You can imagine.
And so then you wonder,
well,
people that are pushing us west whatsapp
with are naive.
Is that whole?
Are they going to eat or are they
willfully blind or are they actually
malevolent,
but they actually aiming at,
now I'll go with naive because that's
the simplest explanation,
but I wouldn't rule out the other ones.
All right,
so let's look at the 20th century
suffered.
Yes,
women's rights.
How did that come about?
Freedom of speech,
labor unions,
the powerful did not want the labor
unions to organize.
How did that come upon?
Freedom of speech,
all of civil rights for black people and
Mexicans,
but Mexicans,
civil rights movement isn't as well
know.
How'd that come about?
How about constitutional protection for
free of fees?
What are the students who it started in
that absolute grassy s virtually
[inaudible].
The free
speech movement started in 1964
[inaudible] 65 after.
Why?
Well,
there was a ban on normal standard
campus political activities and so the
students fought for the right to free
speech and academic freedom and the one,
well,
they weren't since they're on the left,
those people,
right,
they were already ally.
If it's a civil rights movement,
they became the leaders of the students
move with him as he had them anti war
movement to other movements which
depending on free speech.
What about the environmental movement or
the lgbt movement with all,
it's not dependent on free speech for
obviously these were can you support rex
marginalized people?
All they had was their capacity to
formulate an argument to make a sad
sacks if they didn't have the power.
Right?
Right.
Lackeys they didn't have the power.
That's the honey claim,
so we're powered and they have,
they have the power to speak German.
That's actually power.
Its real power and so if you're normally
side,
if you will crest like you claim,
then you should be standing up as
diligently as you possibly can for free
speech because it's the most powerful
weapon you have to write the societal
that you're hypothetically and perhaps
realistically concerned about.
We have to discuss inequality for
example.
You have to discuss it long enough until
we figure out how saw everything from
stacking up at one end of the
distribution and then everyone else
hitting zero,
and this is going to be a big problem.
So example,
yeah,
the Tesla guys,
they're building on top of the sarcoma,
but they're not stupid.
You know,
you ain't going to stop there.
We're building a condoms.
He goes,
they're building robots and robots.
Autonomous Robots are first going to
take the shape of a car.
An autonomous car is no more a car.
Then the car was a horse drawn carriage.
They're not the same thing.
They're not even close to the same
thing.
And they're going to produce societal
transformations that are so radical
lifter unmanageable.
But I can tell you one of the
transformations that going to occur,
what's the most common source of
employment for Man in North America?
Driver,
right?
And so for instance,
the autonomous robots show up,
which isn't going to be very long then
why all those people going to do,
and the answer is they're going to stack
up at zero.
And that's what's already happened in
the United States.
In particular in the rust belts.
I mean,
that's why trump got elected,
right?
Because the Damn Democrats here,
absolute stupidity abandoned the working
class who make important to represent
well,
it's not good.
They're going to be dispossessed people.
It's going to be a big problem and we
need to figure out how to solve it.
And so we need an active laugh.
We need the left.
It actually stands for not postmodernism
and not daredevil,
murderous,
reprehensible.
Marxism like that has to go
[inaudible]
Rodney Times attracting Nazis.
It doesn't seem to be terrific,
but in any case,
that's an accusation,
that's b level.
But here's something strange at
mcmaster.
You know,
there's that big demonstration against
me and uh,
there's of students there,
maybe they were students,
they were professional protest,
your gripes.
And if they were students,
they haven't been educated by the
professors
doctor into what's essentially a call.
And they showed up with a big banner.
It had a hammer and sickle on.
It's like,
what the hell?
No,
I'm serious.
Like this is not funny.
It's not funny.
The circle was mostly used to cut off
people's heads.
What are in the 20th century was no
cocktail and chill.
Yeah.
You still got North Korea to deal with.
Oh,
that wasn't real communism.
your city is,
well,
you see plenty of examples of real
communism,
so I would say you'd have to tell them
university circumstance,
I'll problem because people will know
more dare to go and do a protest without
blood hammer and sickle,
the name of the gear to go in a Nazi
uniform.
What do you mean by social scientists in
universities identified themselves as
Marxists.
It's like,
why the hell is that acceptable?
What does it take for us to learn?
Or obviously a couple of you,
your desk and the Cold War,
nuclear thermal,
nuclear annihilation,
while one is
anyways,
oh,
mnemonics calling investigations that
I've done trying to get to the bottom
have indicated to me that there's
something to the notion of being eternal
human soul.
Now you'd called a metaphor if you want.
That's fine.
Matt,
for us,
turn out to be extraordinarily powerful
days.
How is this sold?
Conceptualized?
Conceptualized is either prophetic
voice,
so [inaudible] Jewish conceptualization
or as the logos and what is that?
Well,
it's the voice that restructures in
equitable social societies.
That's the prophetic voice that makes
the horse,
that transforms the chaos of potential,
which is everywhere around us,
into Howard Bloom order in which that
soul manifests itself.
So the society,
we can be guided by it.
This term,
all through communication,
term free speech limitation on that is
to put a limitation,
I would say on the Holy Spirit itself
and not the sin that cannot be forgiven.
Okay.
And so why would say wait,
stop allowing people to do this.
Then you don't remember.
No one's brandon left,
right?
Whatever
you can possibly do is dependent on your
ability to communicate what you believe
as clearly as possible.
It's your holy duty to do that.
And anyone who interferes with that
interferes with the proper on the phone.
We going to be,
it's up and it's a catastrophe.
Have
universities in shed and the humanities
specifically are the worst offenders.
Thank [inaudible] uh,
I don't actually have a question.
I was just wondering if you could
comment on kind of the before and after
of your life from the point where video
games,
political correctness,
you just want to tell a little anecdote,
a little story about
the vortex.
You got sucked into
the first part.
Mostly it's surreal.
It was
surreal.
Oh,
first of all,
these videos as upset,
I need to
design
apps to church people,
the Apple Watch things at the same time
I started to toy with youtube because I
have a little bit of exposure on public
health issue for Ontario and they get a
from the course.
Um,
and so I put those on youtube and you
know,
people watch them a little bit.
And then I started from my lectures on
the two of them.
I thought that was cool school,
crappy videos and that sort of thing
through,
which was,
you know,
it's a Frankenstein Monster,
like
[inaudible] [inaudible] set up my
patriarch accounting because I was
curious about how cruel people can
monetize their products.
And Patriarchal seems like the
electricity thing.
So I thought I'd explore it.
Best thing to do with that is to get
involved in all
views over three years.
And I had about 10,000 subscribers.
We were talking,
you know us a lot.
That's a long view with a man.
If I sold,
we sold a million copies and B,
you know,
I can do touchdown dances in that.
You would catch that with dances,
ecstasy.
You never see.
And so
in September,
October I be picking on political
correctness for quite a while back,
I was writing a book which is going to
be published in February.
It's called 12 the 12 things everyone
don't hope for life.
An antidote to chaos.
Okay.
Coming down from the facility,
one of those jobs it's called chapters
in that book is called [inaudible].
The children that they're skateboarding
and it's all political correctness and
it's always obsessing me.
Cause if you know,
since you get into that,
it's just takes over your life.
And uh,
I got news,
how would this bill see?
16 then I investigated it.
I also had a couple of clinical clients
would be drinking beyond your limit of
tolerance by politically correct people
in your workplace.
Who are really harassing the hell out of
the name of sensible people.
And so all of that working together when
I thought I was not sleeping one night
and I can either write it or I could get
video,
how to make video and see if like my
cell phone,
it goes to this political practice,
your university and also just what's
going to make it mandatory for their
human resources.
People to either go auntie unconscious
bias training,
which I think is reprehensible.
And so I've made one video tell me about
why I thought bill CC scheme is
dangerous and that we maybe have one
vote antivirus trig and unconscious bias
and uh,
you know,
then I was a little clearer and I
thinking and I thought that was that.
Well,
you know,
listen to people who watched it.
That's your job to feature.
And then it's been a tornado since then
and some of it's great.
Like this is great.
Some of it's not so great,
you know,
it was very worrisome or being for about
two months.
Mostly I would say on behalf of my
family because
my job was in Germany,
right?
Severes here I got my two warning
letters from the university which were
full of lies.
Most of the admissions,
admissions with truth and I know how
companies,
corporations and she's fired people.
They send three letters of warning and
then if they take action,
that's what they were doing going down
the hr tactic and then which they were
continually going down except that I
know about the support and so what
happened to begin with was the
journalists,
they didn't and a good guy,
but some of them actually read the
material while I was waiting on my baby
and thought,
oh,
he's actually just telling people what's
actually in the legislation and they
were journalists
who handed it to be more conservative
about free speech.
Then rose and so going to watch the
journey was started after you my
favorite and then the social justice
warriors play their role because they
came up with a free speech rally and
again,
a variety of cinematically
describing that's
not strategically viable phase.
This is quite educated.
I wouldn't say cynical and dark heart
rate every time that as social justice
warriors you cannot me,
all I have to do is stand back
[inaudible] himself.
I was somewhat confusing,
although expressing no get faster
tobacco.
There's a good example of that.
Like I could just sit back and let
the performance of her because I knew
that a very large number of people that
watch it and it was a very large number
of people did it.
And so like
great.
I
most of the rest of it is just surreal.
I know I do words.
Um,
I don't really have any idea what's
happening.
It's very difficult for me to pick the
proper level of analysis.
I do real deep at the fundamental level
of analysis.
There's the social movements at the
deepest levels feel about,
but I still talking about
what's happening in Alaska somewhere
between philosophical and theological.
Um,
we're in a moment of crisis.
The things can go either way and I'm
hoping that they go through traffic and
I'm hoping that what I'm doing is
facilitating that turned to be very
careful with what I say.
And,
and
then the close is the,
I decided a long time ago that there,
I learned a long time ago that there are
two ways of forgiving yourself through
like why you,
you decide that you want use your layers
to get it.
That's a lot better than not doing
anything.
This is the critical year into like,
except that's not going to use your
language to get what you want.
Okay,
here's another,
you'd use your language to state what
you observe and decentralized as clearly
as you possibly can and let whatever is
going to have.
So that's what I tried to.
So this is all what's happened and
fundamentally it's okay with me because
already decided that whatever the
outcome was of doing that was going to
be okay.
It's an act of faith.
It's Dick after faith action because
you've decided that the world run better
on truth or false.
If you're going to stand on truth,
that's a decision that you speak the
truth and you let the cards fall where
they fall.
And so I was watching where they fall
and I'm trying to stay intact and so far
it's working.
So thank God
Eric.
[inaudible]
yeah,
maybe we could go,
let's,
let's make it a little bit though
because people want to know what the
hell's going on.
So how about 20 hours but time is it,
it's almost like,
okay,
how about 20 after is that I'm doing
okay cause I won't be intelligible after
with open dialogue between the only
thing that helps keep communication
between could do to get a few clients.
How do you connect the people who are
cleaning certain ways to find,
okay,
well first of all I wouldn't say that
necessarily come down,
right?
So there's an analogous problem in
clinical psychology,
which is how,
what do you do to help someone who
doesn't want to be helpful and answer?
It's,
I could use a new guest of quote against
that.
It's another harsh one.
Don't cast pearls before swine.
I took me a long time just going to
escape.
And what it means is that you deem
valuable.
What's valuable by offering it to people
who will not appreciate.
If you can engage to Donald's a summer
and go find someone that you can engage
with and maybe,
and you might say,
well what about those people?
And I would say,
what the best thing to do with them,
the first day of the series you live in
again and burry the desk.
And the second answer is the only way
that you get a person a self if I can
help is by example.
So you'll walk away from people you
cannot communicate with,
you,
communicate with people who you can
communicate with and you try to put your
life in the water and then,
and then you hope that some of the wake
up and some of the well,
so.
Yep.
[inaudible]
thank you very much for your speech
tonight is fantastic.
Um,
my question was dre simple.
it has to do with your crowd funding
academic research,
which we recently did on Coco for
earlier,
I believe it said,
and you raised more than doubles so far.
Your original goal is now $162,000,
which is amazing.
Um,
and I hope the organizers of this event,
we'll post the links,
we can get more money.
But if your question is,
this is the first time I've ever seen a
university research funded by the public
at large as opposed to through one of
the Canadian research councils,
which usually are,
there's a community and there's a
different process.
To me it seems like it's precedent
setting is not willing.
Right.
How would you think this will change the
pattern,
uh,
research funding in Canada?
Well,
that's a good question.
I mean,
one of the things I haven't talked
about,
first of all,
if that's how I'm my campaign,
right?
It's the real community is now they
asked me if they could run it and I said
yes,
but I,
I don't believe I would've done it on my
own because it seemed like,
what did it seem like?
It seems in some sense by capitalizing
on misfortune know and so,
so anyway,
so they did it.
I'm happy about that.
But when they decided to do it,
I talked to a number of people that I
know about what this could conceivably
me.
And one of the things that we thought
about was setting up a system whereby
other professors could do the same
thing.
I've been researchers,
no doors,
some sites like set up,
I think there's one called the spear
mint.com I passed right by the way,
but it does fine with these sorts of
things.
Um,
it might be worth investigating whether
this is say a reasonable and Broccoli
precedent,
but it isn't obvious to me that I have
the time to investigate that old enough
to figure out how to do it.
And that's part of what I'm trying to
figure out right now.
So I'm going to be talking to people
over the next couple of months in all
likelihood.
I have some,
some supporters who are reasonably well
capitalized and they are interested in
working to allow that sort of thing to
happen.
But it's very complicated.
I am,
I'm already walking by and so I know the
answer is I don't know what sort of
precedent and step.
I do know that it's going to keep,
my graduate students were waiting for
the next three years.
So with any luck I'll apply for another
grant this fall and yet,
and then I'll have more money than I
would that would be funding.
So I hope that,
uh,
I'd like to thank you for posting your
videos.
The lectures on the young and archetypes
president of the lion king is worthwhile
if anyone's interested.
My question though is about the limits
and restrictions on free speech.
So honestly we're opposed to anyone who
wants to restrict free speech.
However,
how do we deal with issues like death
threats or dishonest or pernicious to
advertise?
Yeah.
Well are you saying we've already dealt
with that pretty nicely.
Like there are,
there are limits to coerce a speech to
the be,
I think he was home law actually has
dealt with that very,
we see I'm a great admirer of English
common law,
English common wise and the whole legal
system.
Right.
So just so you know,
cause you should've jumped because our
legal system is to come follow it up by
me.
What would you call it?
Intro mission of French civil law
precepts into the English common law
system,
which is catastrophe in my estimation.
Under English common law,
you have all the rights there are and
are granted to you by the government you
have.
And then what's happening in English on
laws when you have some rights and
rights,
common had scrapped because you know,
you don't know where one right ends the
other who begins.
And so then we gave each other the court
and then the court decides roughly
speaking where the line should be drawn
and then the law of builds organically
across content.
And how do we,
now that it's come up with all sorts of,
we could call the limitations on,
I wouldn't say free speech precisely
because I don't really believe that
that's what they are,
but I'm like,
you can't outrun death threats.
So,
and I guess it's partly the paradoxical
situation where sometimes what you're
doing with your free speech is
interfering with the continuation of
free speech,
in which case you should be saw.
It's something like that.
And so,
you know,
there should be limits on seditious
speech of some sort because that's
treasonable speech.
You know?
And I guess if what you're doing is
oriented towards demolishing the
structure upon which your own freedom
depends,
then something has to be there has to be
eliminated.
Now where did evidence should be?
Well that's a tough one but that's,
but a lot of that card would be seven.
You know,
there's lots of things you can't ever
get France you can incite to criminal
activity,
right?
And you can't blatantly lie if you are a
commercial vendor,
in fact been tobacco for example.
And it has to be certain in the Supreme
Court and your ass,
you have to put warnings on your tobacco
product that's compelled speech,
which was what I was objecting to.
It feel see 16 but outside of the
commercial domain there hasn't been any
attempt to compel speech.
And that's how it should.
So I think those things have to agree to
be dealt with on a case by case basis
because the devil's in the details.
And that's also why English common law,
such a staggeringly brilliant
contribution to world culture.
And you know,
if you want to think,
well,
is there any of your collectors for
that?
It's like,
yeah.
Most countries that we're founded on
English
common law are rich
in the Americas.
Founded my friends core funded by
Portugal ports,
founded by Por [inaudible] rich.
So any sligo structure now that's my
home was a great book,
Huh?
What was it called?
The wealth and poverty of nations.
It was written by a Harvard professor
who analyzed,
he was very generous about why some
countries in the Americas we were
pouring,
some are rich because they all have
natural resources,
what's going on.
And so,
and then other countries like Japan,
you know,
we need the resources and the rich are
functioning.
Legal System said is the ultimate
attachment resources.
So it was becoming an yep.
[inaudible]
this relates to Sam Harris has been set.
We will like it,
but I'm just gonna go with it if you
don't mind.
Uh,
so why can't be subjective?
I,
you know,
luther and still fit into your
methodological perspective.
Well see the thing about a question like
that,
this is the truth.
This is the truth about any question
like that.
When you say is a equivalent to be,
the answer is it depends on how you
define it in your hands.
Now you'd find you'd be like,
it's a weasel answer in some sense,
but it's actually the correct answer
because I can't answer that question
without knowing what you specifically
mean by illusion and specifically
meaning about the subject.
Now and I would also say the question is
not that I didn't call because
they are referring to is not homogenous.
It's heterogeneous
of eyes,
you know,
radiation,
something like harvey was something like
a unity after call and some of that of
yours in some sense a losery.
Did he get in the same way that the
desktop on your computer isn't an
illusion.
The representation of the actual
computational processes,
it's more illusory.
It its function.
If you're thinking about illusion as
some,
you see you have to define the physical
arena in which you were formulating the
concepts before.
We could have a proper discussion of
that.
Now that I would say the simple truth
that Ari and here too is that
civilizations that act as if human
beings have freewill seem to work.
Now that's a pragmatic didn't habits,
right?
Sounds scientific,
but I'm a pragmatist so that is pretty
far from me.
And so from a shorthand perspective,
I would say
if something is functional and it's
based on the particular first principle,
the first principle is true enough and
that's where I think about free will and
not sort of thing about the idea of the
soul.
Now I'm not saying that constitutes that
exhaustive analysis of freewill core of
the soul.
It is,
but it's a good first pass
approximation.
[inaudible]
um,
I saw him on your q and a's.
I hope this isn't too unrelated but it's
probably what we keep it lighter.
Um,
you said that you're a big fan of a
guilty pleasure for trailer park boys,
a brief sort of article,
well your hair characters and maybe the
tie back to free speech.
How a show that is so crude and
offensive managers to be making the most
positive
here.
Um,
well I'm from northern Alberta.
I don't know if you know the movie.
Um,
rhubarb.
I went foobar it's actually about the
people that I grew up with.
Pete to some degree having us watch for
the border
probably eight years ago because they
have one of my old friends and we were
scared of swatches.
You know,
I,
there's something about,
I went to the class guys,
I think they're fighting,
they have great senses of humor and
something,
I read this,
one of the ways the working class guys
compete is through observing
for restaurants.
I heard lots of rough places,
rail crews and that sort of thing.
And what keeps guys alive in situations
like that?
Is there a certain sense of humor and
the training of our employees is a great
example that I think it's hilarious that
the Canadian government funds it.
Yeah.
And this is also the simpsons.
It's absolutely reprehensible in all of
its details except for its container,
the simpsons.
The family is central to this instance,
right?
Well to say about homeowners,
like loves his family,
who,
anything for his family and
fundamentally they're oriented towards
each other.
And so it's always a calming because
there anyhow.
And so that's what gives best what makes
the simpsons just mean spirited.
It's not mean spirited.
It's great.
Saqqara everyone's,
he held the Joe and the characters are,
are essentially moral and it's the same,
somewhat lesser degree.
It's like,
because the stories when it's working,
the story is,
well two things.
It's about impulsive,
male stupidity,
also friendship.
And it really is about friendship.
Even the enemies are friends.
And so the creative subject have done
this remarkable job of walking the line
between satirical,
like English to meet needs.
It's great car,
but they have,
they have their characters,
the characters completely reprehensible.
Right?
So that's part of why I left the street,
goes to Vegas.
I think unbelievably funny because you
watch it then have this documentary like
aspect is easy,
but these are real people.
Conky episode down.
I have a bucket list
to be invited on the trailer park.
Okay.
Um,
I just have a question about,
uh,
your plane's on political belief and
direct correlation to big five
personality.
Um,
I,
you mentioned that there's truth ain't
truth be fighting it out in this between
the right and the left.
Um,
what do you mean pass the treaty?
Which is what I see is emerging is the
libertarian movement,
which isn't really in either category.
The first answer is I don't know enough
about libertarians to say because we
haven't been able to sample it off the
boat.
You get a sense now I shouldn't say that
the 23 correct types are not causing,
just so everyone knows the biggest
English or for the politically correct
heights is that they're very high in
agreeableness.
Anyone say,
well,
I don't see very
real.
People are only agreeable to say like,
so if you're in their desk,
then you're gay.
But if you're outside the nest or a
snake and so they're very agreeable
behaves,
but they're not very agreeable to
snakes.
And most people are snakes.
So,
so,
but the is my suspicion is that there
are high in openness and high in
conscientiousness.
I don't know.
I really don't know.
They may also not be very agreeable
because they're kind of like,
leave me the hell times,
which kind of goes with the sort of
people that I,
I'm agreeable,
I'm quite agreeable with the guests.
I find it really hard,
disagreeable types,
basically telling him to screw off and
that can be really useful because that
is what you should do.
I suspect that the Libertarians are more
disagreement.
Okay.
[inaudible]
ah,
so you expressed some concern about
losing your job at University of Toronto
and I was just wondering,
given that you're picture on income,
excuse my own salary,
is there a threshold at which you would
consider resigning and pursuing a
youtube just being oppression of youtube
as your primary?
Well,
you know,
I thought about that,
but as I said earlier,
I like to do both things at the same
time and right now there's no reason to
do that.
I have this great
professor and I should also say on
behalf of when students like,
look,
I went back to teach in January and I
was not in very good shape.
I have real health crisis in December,
which I think was unrelated to this.
We're not,
but I was reading on in good shape and
I,
I had been,
it had been recommended to me by my
chair.
I'm not returned to teaching
independently of what was going on at
the university.
There's no damn way.
I just like,
no,
I wasn't,
but I wasn't clear to me how much
additional stress,
I'm just going to kill the target.
Or the students were extraordinarily
well and he knows the students at the
university trav and most students,
most of them are kids,
are first generation immigrants,
right?
It's like they're on a bloody political
bandwagons frame from their economic
future there post powered by the dreams
and desires of their parents,
and I'm working in south down to the
tailbone.
I'm trying to get her degree in new up
here.
It'd be functioning.
And so I liked the undergraduates.
It a small percentage of it.
Is Paris laws the same?
Damn,
no.
I don't even know how many of them are
students for now.
And then there's the administrative
person,
a fair number of the sites who are
politically correct,
but the university itself is actually
quite conservative in the small sisense.
Now that's annoying sometimes because
I'm right radical from a creative
perspective.
And so I find we have some constraints,
whatever.
I got nothing to complain about this
with the rest of,
it's a highly,
highly privileged job and thrilled to
have.
I'm lucky to have it fortunate.
I like teaching young people.
It's a great privilege to do it.
And so I don't see any reason to stop
and I think there can be both.
And so far that's working.
So as long as the loan,
which is my libertarian aside,
as
long as I left alone by the university
and my gender,
yeah.
Then I can have my cake and eat it too.
And so that's a good deal.
Um,
so earlier in your speech and you
mentioned how the length generally
kind of come to the aid of who they
perceive at as oppressed.
Right.
Uh,
so I kind of view,
uh,
the rights as being sort of a price on
the left to myself.
Uh,
do you think my perception is correct
and if so,
why do you think that the social justice
type don't also see it like I did?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
we're in a time of cat,
right?
Isn't that [inaudible] times things
reverse in twists and,
and we're in many and I believe that
where I do believe that that's
[inaudible] main process has emerged
is the left or pressing the right,
I think it's more like the left has
gained the routing color as being
incremental control over many
institutions as a consequence of
inappropriate public subsidy.
So there not that many of them.
There are whole disciplines that are
pathologically etiological possess,
which like the ethnic studies waiting
studies types where the studies in
particular it's complaining of hospital
and increasingly the humanities are
being pulled into that vortex that have
postmodernism two thirds of the way down
to Marxism.
Underneath that,
the problem is,
is that
set up a system where people are,
that orientation can draw a stable cell
for decades.
There's thousands of them,
hundreds of thousands perhaps and do
nots.
But we're on what they say demo on which
is the underlining of the patriarchy,
which is a reprehensible term.
By the way.
It's a wrongful oversimplification of
the estate and it's also profoundly the
ungrateful because although the
Patriarchy is an oppressive structure
obviously because any social community
requires conformity or it's not a social
community,
it's also staggered in a productive and
for example provides them with a degree
of safety and security.
This unthinkable.
Well they pursued their fifth call
agenda.
We've got to stop.
It's not acceptable and the way we
started in parties,
Harrods,
don't let your children take you.
Never of course
[inaudible].
One of the things that I've been
thinking about doing this,
and this would be a great crowd source
project.
I would like to make up a technical,
if I can do a technical analysis of
postmodern slash Marxist slash social
justice terminology,
you'd be working on that already.
And then great course descriptions,
how of course descriptions raging fires
and publish them.
And so then with brain corridor,
universities and colleges by social
justice infiltration and to do this and
that and produce a manual for parents
and high school students that would say
who not to take courses in which horses
and you avoid because I think that
starving them out is the right approach
and it's going to be difficult because
they'll take your,
and I've been an admirer of 10 but the
system's gone sideways,
that there was a way of exploiting it
and,
and it's being exploited.
I mean the,
I don't know how many of you guys fall
real peer review cat.
I would recommend that one player that
you want to see what the pathological
humor,
these spoilers are up to you as soon as
described the real peer review and it's
like you,
it's,
it's far more observant than to on
so,
so I don't remember what your question
basically is the oppressor to right.
Uh,
and then like recognize some,
well the left,
he has a little pressing the
universities and the universities are
oppressing the culture now with that and
that translates to some degree into what
you're disruptive.
So thank you.
[inaudible] on behalf of the UBC Bruce
Beach Club,
we just wanted the thing,
everyone that are coming out and we want
to think Dr. Peters in determining as
well
are those that we will be seeing some of
you tomorrow where we will be doing the
devouring mother event will be a joint
conversation between Dr. Peters and Hen
Third Myers right there and uh,
that will be live streamed as well along
this way.
And that's going to be on a and media
for now.
And I know that you want a copy of that.
So that's going to be on your channel.
And listen to me eventually.
And,
uh,
what those were.
Those were those.
Yeah.
And that's,
and for those of you who have a VIP
tickets,
you get a phone call as well.
So yeah,
thank for coming out.